We have divided in three our kingdom it is our fast intent to shake all cares and business for my age
Conferring among younger strengths. What can you say to draw a third?
more opulent than your sisters
Nothing my Lord
Nothing will come of nothing, speak again
Where's my daughter?
By day and night he wrongs me. Every hour he flushes into one gross crime or other, that sets us all at odds.
I will not endure it
Who is it that will tell me who I am?
Why not by the hand, Sir?
How have I offended?
You are old. You should be ruled and led by some discretion that discerns your state
Thou art my daughter rather than disease. That's in my flesh.
It's alright brother. It's alright
Here I stand. Your slave. I'm poor, infirm weak & despised on
To whose hands you have sent the lunatic case
I am a man more sinned against than sinning
Better though had'st not been born
And not off pleased me better